Notice that I put this negative sign with the 3 in the numerator. I could have
also put the negative sign with the 1 in the denominator. Doing this allows us
to make some other moves with slope. Instead of going down 3 units and then
right 1, we're going to move up 3 units and left 1. We move left because the run
is negative. So here is my y intercept, and I move up 3 and then left 1. Notice
I still lined up with a point on my graph. And the same is true if I did it
again. So either way that we use the slope we can still wind up with our line.
Just be sure you use the negative in only one of the directions. In this case
the negative was with the rise, which was down. And in this case, the negative
sign was with the run, which is to the left.